[Music]
hey guys recently we finally received
the first official game of thrones
season 8 teaser Entertainment Weekly
always provides the first exclusive look
or what's to come in the next season of
Game of Thrones and this time it's no
different they've finally shared some
legit spoilers for the final season so
if you don't want anything spoiled you
should probably close this video okay
they share the entire season 8 cover
story online a few days ago which
includes a detailed description of the
opening scene the largest battle scene
ever filmed for not only gaming journals
but for the television in general and
much more the final season will open
where we all expected at Winterfell
the opening scene will see the arrival
of John and Danny Peter Cruz at
Winterfell which is said to be similar
to King Robert's arrival in the series
premiere this episode will be an episode
full of reunions so if you've been
waiting for John to reunite with Arya or
for Arya to reunite the hound or for
almost the entire game entrance crew to
be together the same place good news is
we'll finally get it in the very first
episode of the final season beside many
reunions premiere will also feature many
tense first meetings between characters
since I said not to be thrilled that
jump and the need to his fancy new
Targaryen girlfriend at least not at
first
this confirms our discussion of the very
first season 8 clip that we received a
few weeks ago and discuss here on the
channel
when HBO posted this clip I explained
that even though the hug share does not
feel warm at all we should not worry
about Senses intentions or even sense as
possible betrayal over Jon Snow as some
suggested instead I explained that the
reason why censor may be glaring over
Jon shoulder could possibly be Danny and
there even may be attention between
Sansa and Jon's new lover which has now
been confirmed
however the post also states that sense
is not real with Jon bending the knee to
Danny
but notice how it says or at least not
at first as I said in my previous videos
dan is not heading north to conquer the
north but rather to save it and that
something the northern Lords will see
for themselves in the very beginning of
the final season censor will eventually
see for herself who Danny truly is and
what her true intentions are and will
without a doubt accept her as the
North's most trusted Ally and it's only
hope anyways some few episodes later the
White Walkers who finally reach an
attack Winterfell
this episode is directed by me well
supporting the one who directed her home
and battled the bastards this mid-season
battle episode took 55 night shoots at
Winterfell Seth and to our big surprise
enter a big joy this was not only part
of the sequence after the 55 nights of
filming outdoor scenes supposed she
continued shooting the battle at
annexed Orioles for weeks according to a
peter dinkledge an actor we know mr
lannister this battle makes the Battle
of the Basterds look like a theme park
in other words one of the top rated
episodes of Game of Thrones that
featured the battle between John and
remse for Winterfell will by far be
taught by another battle for Winterfell
this time between the living and the
dead the last finale is the scene from
the series finale is also described it's
noted that there are characters in the
last episode of game eternal ski did not
expect we don't know if this means their
characters we do not expect in terms of
them surviving the long or if this means
that there are some unexpected
characters reappearing in the very last
episode of Game of Thrones
perhaps that returns as one of my most
popular theories suggested perhaps reg
returns as one of my another popular
tier States perhaps is just one of the
main characters thriving more than we
expected regardless what better way to
end this video than with the first
official photo from the set of season 8
featuring Jon Snow and Dany and as
always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see in the next time peace
[Music]